الحمد
لله ما توفيقي ولا اعتصامي ولا ثقتي الا
بالله عليه توكلت واليه انيب حسبي
الله احمده تعالى حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا حمدا يليق بجلال وجهه وكمال صفاته
وعظيم
سلطانه يا
ربنا لا نحصي ثناء
عليك انت كما اثنيت على
نفسك واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك
له له الملك وله
الحمد يحيي
ويميت وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان سي نا وعظيمنا وقائدنا
وحبيبنا
وشفيعنا محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه
وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف
الغمه تركنا على المحجه
البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عن ها الا
هالك صلى الله عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين واصحابه
اجمعين ومن سار على نهجهم الى يوم
الدين اخص
بالذكر
امراء المسلمين
بالحق ابي بكر وعمر وعثمان وعلي
وعن
السبطين الحسن
والحسين وعن عمي النبي
الكريمين حمزه
والعباس وعن ازواج النبي الطاهرات من
الادناس
والارجاع وعن بنات النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
زينب
ورقيه وام
كلثوم ولا سيما قره عين
الرسول فاطمه الزهراء
البتول ورضي الله سبحانه
وتعالى عن السته
البرره الذين هم تمام العشره
المبشره وعن بقيه الصحابه والقرابه
والتابعين ومن تبعهم باحسان الى يوم الدين
رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا وعليهم
اجمعين فيا عباد
الله اوصيكم ونفسي المذنبه
الخاطئه بتقوى الله تعالى
وطاعته ولزوم اوامره وكثره
مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون
ايها
المؤمنون واعلموا عباد الله ان التقوى
شعار المؤمنين ودثار
الصالحين ووصيه الله تعالى في وفيكم
اجمعين فقد قال الله سبحانه وتعالى في
محكم
التنزيل اعوذ بالله السميع
العليم من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون صدق الله
العظيم اما
بعد ايها
المسلمون خطبه
اليوم خطبه
مهمه يغفل الكثير
عنها وعن
موضوعها
بل يظن
البعض اننا لسنا
بحاجه الى مثل هذه
الخطب خطبه
اليوم عن
فضل حلق
الذكر الله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول الذين يذكرون الله قياما وقعودا وعلى
جنوبهم ويتفكرون في خلق السماوات
والارض
ربنا ما خلقت هذا باطلا سبحانك فقنا عذاب
النار
وقال سبحانه
وتعالى والذاكرين الله كثيرا والذاكرات
وقال عز
وجل يا ايها الذين امنوا اذكروا الله ذكرا
كثيرا وسبحوه بكره
واصيلا
اعلموا عباد
الله ان
الذكرى باب الله
الاعظم
الذكر باب الله
الاعظم المفتوح
بينه وبين
عبده ما
لم يغلقه العبد
بغفلتي قال الحسن البصري رحمه
الله تفقدوا
الحلاوه في ثلاثه
اشياء تفقدوا
اشياء
فالصلاه وفي
الذكر وفي تلاوه القران
الكريم فان وجدتم بمعنى فان وجدتم هذه
الحلاوه والا فاعلموا ان الباب
مغلق وقد ذكر ابن القيم رحمه
الله فوائد
عده لحلق
الذكر ليس كما يدعي
البعض ان حلق الذكر بدعه ليس لها اصل في
الاسلام
وهذا جهل كبير يرتكبه من يدعي انه من
العلماء
لننظر ماذا قال ابن القيم وهو تلميذ شيخ
الاسلام ابن تيميه رحمه الله
تعالى في
فوائد حلق
الذكر قال
منها ان انه يطرد
الشيطان
ويقمعه
ويكسره ويرضي الرحمن سبحانه
وتعالى
ويزيل الغم
والحزن
ويجرب للقلب الفرح والسرور
والبسط ومن فوائد حلق
الذكر انه يقوي القلب
والبدن وينور
الوجه والقلب
ويجرب
الرزق قال تعالى الا بذكر
الله تطمئن
القلوب
كذلك انه
يكسو
الذاكره
الحلاوه
والمهابه ويورثه محبه الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وانه يكسب
العبد مراقبه ربه عز
وجل
فيدخل في باب
الاحسان لان الذكر
عباده
والاحسان ان تعبد الله كانك
تراه فان لم تكن تراه فانه
يراك و هذه
المنزله لا
تتحقق الا بمواصله ذكر الله سبحانه
وتعالى
والمراقبه لله عز وجل لا تكون الا بذكر
الله سبحانه
وتعالى قال الله
تعالى
فاذكروني
اذكركم اذا ذكرت
الله ذكرك الله سبحانه
وتعالى واحبك الله سبحانه
وتعالى جاء في الحديث
القدسي عن النبي صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
وسلم فيما يرويه عن ربه عز
وجل هذا
حديث في البخاري
ومسلم
وهما اصح الكتب بعد كتاب الله سبحانه
وتعالى قال الله سبحانه وتعالى في الحديث
القدسي فان ذكر فان ذكر في
نفسه ذكرته في نفسي الله
اكبر اذا كنت من
الذاكرين يذكرك الله في
نفسه فقط هذا الامر في نفسك لا هناك امر
اخر وان ذكرني في
ملا يعني مع مجموعه في حلق
الذكر ذكرته في
ملا خير
منهم ايها
المسلمون
اعلموا ان ائمه الحديثي رحمهم الله
تعالى قد
خصصوا في كتب
الحديث
ابوابا
وفصوص
بفضل الذكر وحلق
الذكر فضل الذكر وحلق
الذكر اذا من يقول انها بدعه هو جاءنا
ببدعه
جديده لان ابن عبد البر رحمه الله
تعالى عندما
يفسر قول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من كذب علي متعمدا فليتبوا مقعده من
النار قال ابن عبد البر رحمه الله تعالى
قال يدخل في هذا الحديث من قول النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم ما لم
يقل ويد دخل في هذا
الحديث اذا قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهو يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لم يقل
هذا
الحديث مهم جدا ان نفهم هذه المسائل لا ان
يتنطع لنا بين فتره
واخرى من الجهله من يدعون انه من
العلماء
وقد اخترت لكم ايها
الاخوه بعض من احاديث المصطفى صلى الله
عليه
وسلم
نقلا عن الامام النووي رحمه الله
عليه في
كتابيه رياض
الصالحين
والاذكار
بالمناسبه مهم جدا
كل مسلم
ومسلمه عندهم في مكتبتهم هذين
الكتابين
لانه ستحتاجون في حياتكم اليوميه كتاب
رياض الصالحين وكتاب الاذكار للامام
النووي رحمهم الله رحمه الله
تعالى الحديث
الاول عن فضل حلق
الذكر عن انس بن
مالك رضي الله
عنه ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال اذا
مررتم برياض الجنه
فارتعوا قال وما رياض الجنه يا رسول
الله قال حلق الذكر
قال حلق الذكر رواه الترمذي وقال حديث حسن
صحيح حديث
اخر عن ابي
سعيد رضي الله عنه قال قال رسول الله صلى
الله عليه
وسلم لا يقعد
قوم لم يقل
رجل هنا جاءت بصيغه
الجمع لا يقعد
قوم يذكرون الله عز
وجل الا حفتهم
الملائكه وغشيتهم
الرحمه ونزلت عليهم
السكينه وذكرهم الله في من
عنده وكل الفاظ الحديث جاءت بصيغه الجمع
هذا الحديث في صحيح الامام مسلم رحمه الله
تعالى حديث
اخر عن ابي هريره رضي الله
عنه قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه واله
وصحبه
وسلم ان
لله
ملائكه يطوفون
الطرق يلتمسون
اهل
الذكر
يلتمسون اهل
الذكر فاذا وجدوا قوما
قوما يذكرون الله عز
وجل تنادوا هلموا الى
حاجتكم فيحفونهم
باجنحته الى السماء الدنيا فيسهم ربهم اي
يسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
الملائكه وهو اعلم ما يقول
عبادي تقول
الملائكه
يسبحونك
ويكبرونك
ويحمدونك
ويمجدونك فيقول الرب تبارك
وتعالى وهل
راوني فيقولون لا لا والله ما راوك
فيقول الرب عز وجل كيف لو
راوني قالوا يقولون لو راوك كانوا اشد لك
عباده
كانوا اشد لك عباده واشد لك تمجيدا واكثر
لك
تسبيحا فيقول الرب عز وجل فماذا
يسالون قال قالوا يسالونك
الجنه
يسالونك الجنه فيقول لهم سبحانه وتعالى
وهل
راوها فيقولون لا والله يا رب ما
راوها فيقول عز وجل فكيف لو
راوها فيقول عز
وجل
لو انهم
راوها كانوا اشد عليها حرصا واشد لها طلبا
واعظم فيها
رغبه ثم يقول سبحانه
وتعالى فمم
يتعوذون قال يتعوذون من
النار فيقول الرب عز وجل وهل
راوها يقولون لا والله ما
راوها فيقول رب عز وجل كيف لو
راوها
فيقولون لو راوها كانوا اشد فرارا منها
واشد لها
مخافه قال فيقول عز
وجل
فاشهد اني قد غفرت
لهم
فيقول ملك من
الملائكه فيهم
فلان ليس
منهم فلان جاء
لحاجه انما جاء
لحاجه فيقول رب عز
وجل هم الجلساء
لا يشقى
جليسهم متفق
عليه بمعنى رواه البخاري ومسلم رحمهم الله
تعالى اللهم اجعلنا من الذاكرين امين
واجعلنا من اهل حلق الذكر برحمه منك يا
ارحم الراحمين ادعوا الله وانتم موقنون
[Silence]
بالاجابه
الحمد لله حق
حمده والصلاه والسلام على من لا نبي من
بعده واعلموا عباد الله ان الله تعالى
امرنا بامر بدا فيه بنفسه وثنى
بملائكه قدسه وثلث المؤمنين من عالم جنه
وانسه وقال تعالى قولا
كريما تعظيما لقدر نبينا وتفهيم لنا
وتعليما ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صل وسلم وبارك واكرم وانعم
وتحن
وتعطف على سيدنا محمد طب القلوب
ودوائها وعافيه الابدان
وشفائها ونور الابصار
وضيائها وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد كما صليت على سيدنا ابراهيم
وعلى ال سيدنا ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد
وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا محمد
كما باركت على سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال
سيدنا ابراهيم في العالمين انك حميد مجيد
مكمل علوم الاولين
والاخرين مولانا ومولى الثقلين ابي القاسم
ابي الزهراء
محمد فيا ايها الراجون شفاعته اكثروا من
الصلاه والتسليم عليه فان صلاتكم نور على
الصراط حين تمرون
عليه
خط حلق
الذكر
الله سبحانه
وتعالى this
be
any
‏meing
sit
and which means
and
‏say
me
remember
frequently anda him
in
in serv of
الله
‏it can
be
forgetfulness حسن
البصري
الله
ذر
[Silence]
قران الله
‏s امام ابن القيم رحمه
الله
‏men some the
benit
[Silence]
cfe
الله
‏and and
another brings joy and happiness to the
heart الله سبحانه
وتالى
mefor سبحانه
among body and heart
stronger brings light to the face and
heart and
increases bounty and
blessings
the in ذكر
[Silence]
الله
احسان
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
[Silence]
ذكر
me
ان احاديث
قدسي الخاري
مسلم رحمهم الله تعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله
اكبر
‏anders me in
a i will remember him in
a
may
them
[Silence]
احث رحمه الله
تعالى بك